so one of the major goals of the course
is for because we all speak a language
or sometimes many languages and while
the students get to understand at the
end of the course is that we all hold
dear certain attitudes about language
and some of it attitudes are positive
for us doesn't for others but often
times and this is actually one of the
major issues that we discuss throughout
the course is that sometimes we have
attitudes that have a negative impact
severe negative impact on the lives of
other people the lives of sometimes
entire communities and Nations so so I
hope throughout that students can
actually take the theory Dallas's in the
course and see ways in which they can
apply it to themselves to the
communities to the countries so clearly
the case that I that I have in mind the
most is my own Haiti where attitudes
about language I've been under one of
the engines that have really gone
against the interest of most Haitians
that have allowed if you to keep the
maturity and the oppression but then
this is true also for the communities so
I was very pleased to see that the
students took that objectives very
dearly and including some who in the
course of this class I've applied
whether what they've learned and taken
it outside including volunteering in say
this virtual English program that just
started in in Boston is a Jewish program
promoting the use of both in Creole in
English and where students are immersed
from kindergarten in both cruel in
English and now this is related to that
class
my class and was volunteering in in that
classroom for kindergarteners who are
learning in Creole and in English and to
me that's a dozen as a dream because
it's one case where what you learn in
the course can be directly applied in in
the real-world contexts which can make
actual positive change in the lives of
these children